إنه أشهر مكتب على هذا
الكوكب حيث تم شن الحروب ، حيث
تمكنت الكوارث من إدارة جدرانه المستديرة التي
شهدتها بعض أكثر
لحظات الديمقراطية الأمريكية دراماتيكية
وكل أربع أو ثماني سنوات
يتحول حيث يغير شاغله
ديكور رموز المكتب البيضاوية
حول رؤية الإدارة
للبلد
وفي أول يوم كامل للرئيس بايدن
في البيت الأبيض ، دعونا نلقي نظرة
داخل المكتب البيضاوي على اليسار
الآن ،
استبدل بايدن المكتب الحازم صورة أندرو
جاكسون التي عرضها الرئيس ترامب
واستبدله بها.  صورة
لبنجامين فرانكلين وهو
يعطي الحذاء لأحد الرؤساء الأكثر
إثارة للجدل
في أمريكا لصالح أحد الآباء المؤسسين
الذين قدموا مساهمات ضخمة في العلوم ،
ولم يكن من قبيل المصادفة أنه يظهر
بشكل بارز جنبًا إلى جنب مع عرض صخور القمر
حيث يعد هذا البيت الأبيض بجلب
الحقيقة  والعلم يعود إلى البيت الأبيض ،
ثم خلف المكتب اختار بايدن
عرض تمثال نصفي لأمريكي لاتيني
زعيم الحقوق المدنية والعمالية سيزار
تشافيز الذي حفيدته بالمناسبة هي
مديرة الشؤون الحكومية الدولية في بايدن
وبالطبع كما
ترون هناك صور عائلية
وهذا يتضمن صورة
معروضة بشكل بارز لعاشق الشمس الراحل
على
يمين المكتب  أعاد بايدن
اللوحة الشهيرة شارع المطر
إلى الشكل البيضاوي ، اكتمل المشهد الوطني
في عام 1917
حيث كان دخولنا إلى الحرب العالمية
الأولى وشيكًا
، كما تم تعليق هذه اللوحة الزيتية في
الشكل البيضاوي أثناء إدارتي أوباما وكلينتون
ثم عبر  تتميز غرفة جدار
بايدن البيضاوي
برسومات جورج واشنطن أبراهام
لينكولن
توماس جيفرسون ألكسندر هاميلتون و
FDR الذي قاد البلاد بشكل خاص
خلال عدة أزمات في وقت واحد وهو
بارز جدًا هناك
وما هو مثير للاهتمام أيضًا عندما تنظر
إلى هذه الصور هو جيفرسون و
صور هاميلتون لأنهما
بجوار بعضهما البعض على الحائط على الرغم
من شهرة هذين الرجلين د  يتفق الجميع على
أن الشكل البيضاوي مليء بإشادات أخرى
لشخصيات تاريخية أمريكية ، وهناك
تمثال نصفي لمارتن لوثر كينغ جونيور ، وهناك
أيضًا أحد الشخصيات الرئيسية لروبرت كينيدي
في حركة الحقوق المدنية
بالإضافة إلى حدائق روزا التي رفضت
التخلي عن مقعدها  أشعلت حافلة في مونتغمري
ألاباما في عام 1955
مقاطعة للحافلات
أجبرت المدينة في النهاية على دمج
نظام
حافلاتها
ثم إليانور روزفلت واحدة من السيدات الأوائل الأكثر أهمية في أمريكا
بالإضافة إلى دانيال ويبستر الذي كان
السناتور السابق الذي دافع بشراسة عن
الاتحاد
ولكن لم يعد  هناك تمثال نصفي
لنستون تشرشل الذي عرضه ترامب
بشكل بارز على
المكتب الحازم
نفسه ، هناك هاتفان ، هناك
مجموعة فنجان وصحن وهو شيء
لم نره خلال فترة
سلف بايدن الذي كان من عشاق الكوكا الحمية ،
كان ترامب  نادرًا ما يتم تصويره مع فنجان قهوة
بجانبه
ويقال إنه كان لديه زر لاستدعاء
أحد الموظفين لإحضاره إلى طريقته المفضلة
هناك تباين ملحوظ
آخر وهو
أقلام بايدن ، وهناك صندوق منها
يمكنه استخدامه لتوقيع الطلبات ،
وهذا ليس بالأمر غير المألوف
ولكنه يختلف تمامًا
عن علامات نمط شربي التي
تستخدم في جعل توقيعه كبير الحجم بارزًا
على المستندات
و  حتى كرسي المكتب مختلف ، يمكنك
أن ترى بايدن ، رأيناه جالسًا على
كرسي من الجلد البني الداكن معنقدة بعد المقعد التنفيذي
البني المحمر السميك لترامب
والذي كان مطابقًا إذا
لم يكن هو نفسه
الذي استخدمه قبل أن يصبح
رئيسًا وبايدن أيضًا
قاموا بتبديل السجادة لديهم
بساط مكتب بيضاوي ذهبي أصفر قاموا بتبديله
ووضعوا
سجادة زرقاء عليها
الختم الرئاسي وتحيط بها حافة
زهرية مسؤول مع عمليات مكتب بايدن البيضاوي
يخبر مركز واشنطن
أن الاقتباس كان  من المهم
أن يسير الرئيس بايدن في شكل بيضاوي يشبه
أمريكا